yellow welcome to a new video and this
will be somewhat different to other
videos it sound 15-minute game and i'll
be playing against my friend brandon DM
inch s cube um and he will do a
comentary on as well so we'll have a
dual comentary so you can watch my video
and also his video to compare what we
both um yeah thought about the game saw
kick off with you for here let's see
what he plays plays all kinds of
openings if i if i can get mistaken aha
french so should i go for something
special okay d for first and now we have
i'm not sure what line is playing if i
go on right c3 for instance i'm not sure
what is playing what okay let's see of
course black smoke made a main choices
here all night f6 bishop before in
taking only form ok Knight f6 see place
yeah now White has two choices mostly
five and Bishop g5 if either so maybe
the most common move now we should be
five or so not bad as well I'm not quite
sure what he's playing poker at let's
play five and continue with the main
line here if you really don't know so
much about an opening at you saw to find
yourself playing it but you know what
the main line is and very often it's a
good idea to just play the main line
don't be afraid that your opponent erm
maybe knows more than you this is very
likely to happen if he's a specialist in
the opening but so often the main line
is just the yeah the main line for some
reason so and often you found it easier
to to actually find the moves over the
board in the in the main branches then
in some young sideline yeah black now um
set a crossroads he can play all kinds
of moves here taking on d4 going to be
six attacking be two can also play a six
there should be seven I mean all kinds
of rules have been tried basically
everything that doesn't learn the
material may be the choice is some yeah
in a way out so matter of taste so it
took on D Phi now black usually do some
ship c5 trying to complete development
and prepare kingside castling not quite
sure if there are some other moves
we have to think Queen B 6 going to be 6
s also move attacking beat you okay it
takes on the form and now Bishop c5 yeah
the sir this line in a German it is
sometimes called the vacuum cleaner
variation because like usually not takes
on d4 Queen D for Queen B 6 trying to
exchange Queens even leading to a very
solid position in which white arguably
has lighted the better chances but it's
not it's not too big of a problem for
black so like an often defend this kind
of position I mean take Queen takes
Queen B 6 this line and white even can
try to to sacrifice with Queen d2 I
think as power plant this in a game but
I'm not too sure about the consequences
yeah what else could like do like good
cosplay a move like castles or a 6 a-6
often to prevent to prepare a b5 but if
you take on d4 you should really
continue with this simplification policy
of taking again and Queen B 6 otherwise
then this exchange was a bit early okay
so can I now take advantage of this that
he took so early not shown long castles
with the air would be the normal move
but white can also play on stuff like g
3g 3 Bishop g2 which is also not bad at
all
yeah try this quite solid way of playing
along castles as mentioned it's also fun
long Castle often involves those kind of
race situations my black plays be five
before advance this is Queen side and
white pushes gyh 4g 5h 5 and so on kind
of similar to a Sicilian defense wear
white pushes on the King side and black
on the queenside and this g3 Bishop g2
set up on a small for positional way to
play with white or a strategical way of
you hello everyone because some
whitewall book has a short and try to
prove that still black has this bishop
on c 8 which is not the greatest piece
so we should to know I'm not quite sure
if if i should play a move like a for
maybe to prevent be five even but b5 can
also be a loosening move weakening a
black screen side in the long run so i
just continue with the normal Bishop g2
here so what what should like do now I
guess b5 would be would be the normal
kind of move
what I need to be cautious off here's
some sorry a maneuver like Knight b6 to
see for because this Bishop is on g2 now
and it doesn't cover the sea foursquare
anymore so now I don't see for would be
a quite annoying piece so I'm I need to
be aware of that okay no it took I'd
have six interesting
okay check first if I have some tactics
going stuff along the lines of 95 but
this shouldn't work I like a move here
maybe if I would have I've gotten would
have gotten long castles and then even
then maybe sacrifice would work okay
what I don't want is after let's say
castles that he takes only five and I
need to recapture with the pawn the c5
porn can be a constant source of worry
so I i grep on on f6 cm and now it's a
question how he wants to set up his
pieces
and in this kind of structure you also
see the benefit of g3 as g3 nicely
covers at four he doesn't have any
direct threat against the f4 porn let's
say after Queen f 6m to Queenie of six I
could could consider to Castle long or
play rook do you wanna move like this
because FY is protected okay yeah what I
actually expect Queen f6 now it makes
her it makes sense I think to play this
I mean rookie f6 looks completely weird
how would I mean black needs to somehow
untangle has his pieces here once he
played f6 it's difficult to imagine that
he would play be five because be five
who should be seven would weaken e6 okay
so he just recaptured with a night and
yeah not bad of course so what should I
do now I mean long castles I don't don't
think makes any sense anymore so I just
cancel short him I have nice control
over the center Queen on d4 and this
week square on e5 the only issue here
really is some my knight on c3 this
piece is not optimally placed it would
be very nice on d4 d5 not quite sure
what's better I mean give divorce maybe
even better because I'm d for the night
would attack e6 really and put some
direct pressure on on the pond only five
it would be very nice but it wouldn't
attack anything so very often the night
is better even yeah 11 square closer to
white scam not not only five okay Bishop
d7 now okay wants to go maybe rook c8 c4
um
of course I need 21 calculator also a
move like fyf is not out of the question
on technically f5 takes 95 and maybe I
have some something concrete down but in
fact you can play Bishop c 6 cm should
see 69 f6 Queen f6 and and it all sort
of evaporates okay so through choc forum
that sir thats idea
hmm
yeah the question is some how to set up
the pieces now I would really like to
get a night on deform but it's not so
easy to accomplish I would need quite
some preparation moves to to get this in
the bishop on g2 also SMS apiece the
questionable merited it it puts some
pressure on d5 but of course the five is
protected and I cannot really make a
five work here Roxy for is really am and
somewhat annoying moves if you would get
this in and you wouldn't if I wouldn't
need to move the Queen Queen B 6 with
check coming be to hanging and so on and
if i play move like let's say 92 here
you might consider Bishop b5 yeah I'm
not sure maybe I cannot retreat the
Queen as a prophylactic measure don't
see a good square quit b6 coming I think
I'll plate this move here the rook is
good hand on the EVO and if you place
rook c8 I play Bishop f1 covering c4 and
therefore keeping the Queen on d4 which
is really a strong piece here I might
even regroup the Bishop to d3 because on
d3 it would cover the sea to pawn also a
sort of ideal configuration would be
Bishop to d3 knight on d4 and then pile
up only six because the three bishop and
the knight on d4 would protect c2 and d3
bishop also covers a form so that ever
night lens only for I can always chop
this yeah I like the idea we should have
one to d3
what I need to be cautious of a bit is
the King position I mean he's very far
away from from getting something on my
king I hope that at least but the bishop
on g2 always is a natural defender of
the king and if you move it away to
let's say d3 you need to be aware of
possible counterclaim but at the moment
it's it's not it's not easy to see how
black should get something on my king
yeah once the bishop is on d3 I can
think of maybe I'm Queen Queen somewhere
not quite sure well Queen f2s always
kick by an IG phone then could be six
check yeah okay but maybe I don't really
need to move the Queen iya that's also
not sure if this move is really doing
much I mean Quincy five would be a dream
move for me I mean okay this is some
sort of according to plan place Quincy
five now this would be I think a huge
positional mistake you shouldn't
exchange Queens here
only question is how short how should I
play then Quincy five mmm the issues if
I could take a take on c5 Roxy 592 you
might play Bishop b5 and I'm not quite
sure what this is but I think it's just
good for me right yeah well I think I
think this is a mistake you shouldn't
exchange Quincy em because i have this
disadvantage and the center here and
pressure only 692 I was a bit worried
about Bishop b5 maybe but I think I can
just play an IP phone as a direct answer
and then e6 is some attacked two times
we should be 594 this is a very nice
piece configuration then because the
knight on d4 cover see to all the time
and it cannot be dislodged from Defiance
no pawn pawn move or anything to get rid
of the night once it is on the farm so I
don't think he has any means to prevent
94 now 94 and then I'll start piling up
only six and he's absolutely not it's
got no counter play at all Black is
suddenly are able to to defend these e
cigs but it's a very passive position
moves like rook e8 King f7 and so on
would protect you six but it's just a
very one-sided affair where black
doesn't have any play at all
yeah this is the kind of position you
don't want to have in the French French
defence this kind of pawn structure with
d5 and d6 where the spawns cannot move
that I cannot move the pawns um it's
always tricky for like mmm now another
thing of it and I was just briefly
thinking maybe if I would be it would be
an idea but it's not working at all okay
so if I would take now and he can take
with the rook I'd actually win the tempo
and be too so I play here and if it
takes on d3 now seat XD 3 this is a
great point configuration yeah it looks
like why does weaken dis pawns but the
porn on d3 is just great because it
covers a form before as my main weakness
en disposition the night is always sort
of threatening to go to your form so
it's it's very good often to have a pawn
transferred from c2 to d3 to cover the
sensitive square and if you look at this
Queen side configuration with CT XD 394
Black has no entry points the knight on
d4 protect c2 and rook on c5 cannot go
to be five it sort of fortress like I
cannot do anything on the queenside and
in the meantime I'll just pile up on a
six this concrete position is success is
even lost immediately so this is
actually I'm close to being lost here
think we should be five from simply the
position couldn't stand black wood could
have defended passively with rocky aid
King f7 and and and boost like this it's
no fun but the game would continue yeah
and now he six is hanging two times and
you cannot cannot protect it and the
most important is some Pisco
not going to play nothing this knight on
d4 is just yeah the French French
defense nightmare so to say always like
this the night is a nightmare yeah well
black cannot cannot do much it's only a
choice is now 22 look how to how to
sacrifice the poor now okay so this is
actually a good idea because of a take
he might enter on c2 we are good idea
didn't really am appreciate that
oh ok but it's um hmm third Roxy one
whoopsie one but it could take and play
you five who this is maybe a somewhat
tougher than I thought
so but let's say I play wiki to ya
covering the second rank and play rook
e1 and then take with the night on you
sexy should be a right okay rookie to ya
there should be okay and okay king of
seven rookie one and it's not not
dependable and if he goes let's say rook
c7 now I can also check it six rookie
seven rookie one if you take the night
without ER okay 10
yeah should be able to take it next move
with them the night basically just 96
and return to deform so that keep this
extra porn and still have the
second-ranked covered yeah here's some
getting very low on time here very
unusual for my games that I'm so white
on time he really needs to move now
otherwise sir it will get get useless
this game because we cannot manage the
time you six is Sam is gone now I think
it's a bit of a shame that the clock is
running down because I think the
technical part of the game would have
been still instructive yeah I can just
just ignore this okay so 96 now right
it should be okay so i can actually win
another poor Nia 95 he needs to protect
yate and so I can take h7 now so guess
this is this looks quite enough so take
now do I have something better even okay
night here and look the 494 to expand
center and so the overwhelming structure
yeah just King f3 and push the pawns
yeah time tom loss but ok the serm is
manageable King to f3 and well g for 5 h
4 and so on two extra points and still
note the the great central configuration
something um you need to really am yay
appreciate that this knight on d4 pawn
on d3 is a very nice configuration
against the the pawn on d5 s those
squares usually controlled by the the
pawn are protected by the three and this
night it's sort of keeping it all
together yeah i still hope you enjoyed
the game and i also post the link in the
description may be somewhat later not
sure check it um to to have them comment
ça offer Brandon the black player on his
channel yeah thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you soon in a new video